I will be permanently moving to Europe
with my family show sampling schools has
helped me back a great job offered there
will be the 60 salary high we cannot
wait to start our new life in Finland we
are also excited hey I am
and I am currently living in Algeria I
am working as Chief Information
Technology officer at aristiles after
working for 23 years in IIT sector in
Algeria I felt that my career had become
stagnant here I wanted to experience
what is like to live in Europe so I
started applying to various jobs there
as someone who is responsible for making
the decision I wanted to upgrade my
skills I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a personal
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
cloud computing and association with
Caltech concept video
it's not easy to get access to Caltech
but simply didn't provide that with this
course I had the choice to study while I
continued it with my job
either Technologies like ews and Azure
during the course luckily my new
employers were looking for someone who
knew this Technologies I have just
completed the course but my new
employers were aware that I was taking
this course and that is how I got this
new job offer with 60 salary high in
Finland I will be leading the cloud
computing unit of my new company
I am really excited not just for myself
but for my family as well I have 30
dollars I think I will be able to help
them with their higher studies in Europe
as a father you always want to make
decision that have a positive impact on
your children as for me I am going to
live my dream now I think dreams come
true when you work hard to achieve them
[Music]